c'est parti bon alors ton léger retard
vous parler aujourd'hui d'un très grand
joueur entendu vous connaissez son nom
puisqu'il a gardé son ouverture qui
aujourd'hui cité par son nom c'est à
dire c'est rui l'eau baisse louis lopez
ségolin montrer alors donc la couverture
ici à l'écran de son ou livres que j'ai
donc réédité récemment ça ça fait pas
encore un an qu'il a été qu'ils étaient
publiés dont bruno pdci voir le nom de
son livre qui a été écrit donc en 1561
c'est livre de l'invention libéral et
par du jeu d'échecs alors ces points
qu'il a écrit ce livre là moi même le ya
encore deux ans je savais pas en fait on
pouvait se douter qu'il a écrit quelque
chose puisqu'on connaissait les
informations sur sa vie est bon comme
qui les grives assez dur mais soyez vrai
n'est pas connu autorise la pâte été
réédité du tout depuis 400 ans en fait
c'est un peu dommage parce que vous
savez que jeu d'échecs a une histoire
très très longue
on parle de 1500 ans voire plus ça
dépend si on me donne des ancêtres vers
d'autres jeux comme la fraude ou
l'ironie ou le
cnet le 3e j sien d'autres je encore
donc c'est une histoire très longue et
on a des champions ont connu on a les
arbres dans les années 1700 800 points
après jésus-christ on a quelques
manuscrits sont là c'est pas des livres
en encore quelques traces avaient des
problèmes mais les premiers livres
véritablement assez complet on en a à
partir du 12ème 13ème siècle dans un
livre de jacques de cessole qui était un
dominicain un moine dominicain qui avait
écrit un traité de morale du jeu
d'échecs
il faut savoir qu'à cette époque et
jusqu'à oui lopez qui est prêtre
important de citer cette cette
information c'est un prêtre s'est passé
pas un hasard il faut savoir que donc à
cette époque le le jeu en général et
plus ou moins transcrit par l'église
notamment les jeux de hasard et ceux qui
jouent avec deux avaient de l'argent
ceci étant dit il se trouve que ces deux
c2 ecclésiastique que sur jacques de ses
sols où oui aux fesses ou même loup
c'est l'année peut-être entendu par les
deux bouts cénac et le fameux pont de
lucena quitte une ouverture connu on va
reparler tout à l'heure pour bien vous
situer le problème ici était il était
prêtre aussi donc
et ils ont essayé justement de faire
bien comprendre à l'église et donc in
fine et à la société puisque c'est un
peu les lisent qui donne le temps un
terreau de moralité de ce qu'on pouvait
le faire on préfère que le jeu d'échecs
lui est exclu et le hasard justement est
comme une exclu et le hasard il
il est levé plus tôt le sens moral
plutôt que la bce donc c'est un gros
travail qu'ils ont fait c'est ça qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est dans leur
livre il ya beaucoup
il insiste beaucoup sur cet aspect là et
c'est pas neutre et on sent bien la
pesanteur du corps si vous voulez de
l'époque
concernant ses activités là ça nous
faisait un peu étrange et aujourd'hui
mais c'est important pour resituer le
contexte et comprendre comme un jeu
d'échecs comme ça s'est formée à partir
de à partir de ce moment là alors pour
bien vous situez justement cette
histoire je vous ai fait un petit
graphique ici de parler du livre
concrètement qui vous situe le la
dimension historique de ce livre par
rapport aux autres grands champions
d'échecs alors en abscisse ici en bas en
votant en horizontal vous avez les dates
à partir de 1450 pourquoi parce que 1450
c'est l'invention de l'imprimerie
d'accord du thé vert tout ça vous
connaissez non mais vous connaissez
peut-être pas la date mais je vous le
dis c'est 1450 jusqu'en 1900 alors
pourquoi je me suis arrêté en 1900
places qu'à partir 1900 on a le premier
en fer 1886 pour être exact on a le
premier champion du monde officiel qui
était wilhelm stiglitz avant steinitz a
pas de champion du monde officiel et les
champions du monde officieux si on veut
philidor était considéré comme le
meilleur par exemple mais s'il n'y a pas
de championnat du monde à proprement dit
donc 1451 sur l'imprimerie donc le livre
de lucena qui est le premier livre
d'échec un primé de l'histoire
ça c'est intéressant à noter quand même
c'est 1497 c'est pas très longtemps
après l'invention d'une primo il
finalement d'accord alors vous savez
aussi que cette date est importante j'y
reviendrai aussi pour l'espagne puisque
oui lopez et espagnol puisqu'on est cinq
ans après 1492 donc après la découverte
de l'amérique
et vous savez que l'espagne ensuite tout
le siècle qui va suivre c'est à dire les
années 1500 jusqu'à 1600 et l'espagne va
dominer le monde
en tout cas au moins l'europe et le
comme l'europe à la à l'époque est sans
doute le monument de plus avancé
technologiquement c'est c'est un empire
dont on disait d'ailleurs que le soleil
ne se couchait pas dessus parce que
charles quint ça va de l'autriche aux
flandres à l'espagne bien entendu jusque
donc aux amériques donc évidemment ça
fait quand même une sacrée trotte
donc lucena 1497 ensuite un livre
important et il nous intéresse
particulièrement vous allez voir
pourquoi dans le livre un livre de
damiano 8,1 portugais ont là aussi des
portugais et un imaginaire tout ça vous
savez que c'était des grands navigateurs
aussi et qu'ils ont participé activement
à la conquête des amériques aux côtés
des espagnols donc damiano qui était un
portugais qui écrit donc aussi en ligne
en début d année 1500 et rui lopez lui
né en 1530 et qui nous intéresse ici et
ici là il meurt en 1580 donc il vit pas
très vieux à l'époque dont vous pouvez
voir alors pourquoi il ya des bars
vertes et rouges en fait la transition
vers rouge c'est le moment où justement
vous écrire leurs livres pour ses
auteurs ils ont écrit qu'elle livre
majeur dans leur vie et il est marqué
par le vraiment le trait vertical si on
prolonge et sur l'acte vous aurez la
date alors pour ce livre qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui c'est 1561 date
exacte pour 1561 il est né en 1930
donc ça pue le seul effet 31 ans donc
c'est intéressant à noter alors ensuite
après rue lopes un joueur aussi assez
connue devrait le connaître je pense est
un italien qui s'appelait le greco hall
elle écrit son livre d'ailleurs en
français et qui sont italiens parce
qu'ils avaient parcouru l'europe mais il
se trouve qu'il a il a pu éditer son
livre d'abord en français et alors c'est
un livre qui ne comprend pas autant de
richesses de commentaires que celui de
rue lopez ou même de damiano et de
lucena qui sont assez assez descriptif
grieco c'est plutôt un recueil de partie
avec relativement peu d'explications et
puis alors il ya une espèce de blanc là
j'en ai parlé à l'historien ou des
échecs aussi nicolas giffard lui dit il
faudrait quand même tu me trouves
problème là parce que toutes les années
1600 et à personne alors faut dire que
le greco est mort jeune ceci pour
expliquer cela il est mort à ces jeunes
et donc peut-être donc sans successeur
sans qu'il ait eu le temps de faire un
match face à un successeur en quelque
sorte et donc il n'y a peut-être pas eu
de grands joueurs de ce niveau là qui a
laissé une trace entre eux greco donc et
le fameux philidor alors philidor ait
quand même un peu plus tard édition de
son livre en 1749 pour ça qu'il ya de
très verticale et réédition du livre ont
complété en 1777 tout ça j'en parlerais
vendredi et puis enfin derrière vous
avez commencé à voir des auteurs un peu
moderne alors stockton alors il est en
rouge complet parce qu'il écrit
énormément de livres vers lui stanton
seul un anglais donc là on est sur la
domination anglaise la révolution
industrielle etc et enfin donc le
premier champ tout le monde
wilhem steinitz qui nous a laissé aussi
un bel ouvrage sur la fin de sa carrière
voilà donc alors pour moi pour en
revenir à ce livre de rue lopez vous
expliquer comment alors voilà le bas
vous voyez c'est quand même c'est pas un
petit livre donc je les mets sur traduit
alors je me suis dit quand même cogné m6
on peut dire donc de l'espagnol très
anciens ce que j'ai lu dans le texte
pour essayer d'être au plus près alors
ça se lit assez bien quand même hein on
si vous avez l'original face à cela
c'est bien ils ont on arrive à suivre
parce que l'orthographe très différente
je sais pas si les hispanisants par une
voûte parmi vous non bon ben alors en
espagnol notamment nous tous beaucoup le
z
vous savez la feta dire des mots divers
maux et c'est pas utilisées à cette
époque là ils disent le sait c'est
didier bizarrement comme en français le
sait c'est dire
on le sait s'est dit que c'est très
surprenant pour une espagne dans parce
que ça n'existe pas aujourd'hui en
espagne on utilise le z mais pas le pas
du tout c'est dit bref mais une fois
qu'on a compris ses particularités
orthographique
quand on lit le texte disons
phonétiquement on s'y retrouve
pas de grande différence avec l'espagne
moderne les grandes différences que j'ai
dû rencontrer qui m'ont posé des
problèmes
c'est surtout le vocabulaire c'est à
dire qu'il ya des termes très anciens on
n'est même pas de quoi il s'agissait
il fallait il a fallu que je trouve des
dictionnaires anciens romans pour le
traduire donc c'est entièrement traduit
et moderniser alors qu'est ce que
j'appelle moderniser aussi bien sûr
beaucoup de beaucoup de parties d'échecs
il ya beaucoup de parties d'échecs dans
le livre cd trois quarts du livre c'est
quand même pas mal de parties d'échecs
mary lopez tout comme philidor
d'ailleurs écrit à cette époque ce qu'on
appelle la notation descriptive
alors je vous le fais quand même vous
comprenez qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui pour
jouer le coup de cavaliers g1 en f3 que
ce soit henri lopès de philidor ils vont
dire si je traduit en français
le cavalier qui est sûre la première
case du cabinet du roi sert acasiens
alors que le cahier de la dame c'est la
case b1 donc le cavalier ou la pièce sur
le sur la première occase du carré des
droits va sur la troisième case du fou
du roi et non pas la troisième case de
la tour du roy cavalière trois voiliers
le bassin plein il y en espagnol et
carioca est un acacia les ailes cariou
del rei il va à la terre ce terrain des
halal fil des règles bon ça fait trois
phrases pour le faire car les j3 établir
trois là donc c'est un peu long au début
mais finalement se disent et raccourcie
à la fin c'est quand même facile à
traduire parce que il ya moins de moules
à la fin évidemment peu au début mais il
faut comprendre que si vous lisez le
texte vous allez vous cogner sa peau
alors c'est vraiment pas simple parce
que si vous savez plus quelqu'un à
quelqu'un c'est de jouer
s'il vous dit lecavalier du roi va sur
la troisième case du fou du roi si c'est
les noirs c'est canal et m6 la même
phrase donc si vous trompez de couleur
vous savez où vous êtes voyez que c'est
compliqué parce que c'est pas séparés en
colonne donc plus blanc noir c'est
vraiment c'est des phrases qui se
suivent donc faut vraiment suivre les
coups un par un et pas se tromper
bon alors évidemment s'est traduit comme
intel 1 je voulais me mois en natation
âgée briques donc dans ce livre c'est un
notation
qui donc ça se lit facilement qui plus
est il n'y a pas du tout des chics et à
l'époque il faut savoir avant donc ses
débuts de l'imprimerie imprimés ça coûte
cher
donc il essaie de faire le moins de
pages possible donc ya pas de graphiques
dans le livre de lucena je me suis
aperçu puisque j'ai pu j'ai pu y accéder
je me suis aperçu qu'il ya quelques
pages où il ya des échiquiers pas
beaucoup mis en a quelques-unes dans se
déroule à pézilla n'a aucun sens du
texte condensé il n'y a même pas de
sauts de pages quand on change de trafic
de deux chapitres pardon quand on charge
de chapitres il n'y a pas de ça c'est à
la suite quoi un chapitre 1 puis les
cliniques ses phrases et puis hop ils
souhaitent la ligne chapitre aux deux
hommes voilà c'est tout est condensé n'y
a pas de tromper on sent qu'il ya une
économie
donc c'est assez difficile un peu
rébarbatif à lire mais en fait une fois
traduit anciens chais devant c'est
vraiment un livre extraordinaire d'abord
en termes historiques bien sûr parce
qu'on apprend énormément de choses on va
en parler mais en termes de langue c'est
vraiment aussi beau parce qu'on est dans
une langue ancienne avec les façons de
parler avec des façons d'écrire qui sont
vraiment spécial
et puis alors en terme de parties
d'échecs c'est aussi assez surprenant
est magnifique
j'ai regardé je crois que j'ai dû
repérer en tout peut-être deux fautes
techniques dans l'ensemble je sais pas
des 50 ou 60 parties qui me propose je
ne peux être repéré deux fautes et
emploi c'est dès 2000 faute mais c'est
vrai qu'il a oublié un moment donné
ou s'agit bien de commenter un petit peu
mais j'ai vraiment pas rajouter ça dans
le texte d'un j'ai mis ça en bas de page
j'ai bien respecter le texte et j'ai
rien à vous dire beaucoup de notes 464
pages il doit y avoir quelque chose
comme 420 note de bas de page quand même
pour donner des indications
supplémentaires donc j'essayais d'être
de bien noter toutes les remarques que
je faisais dans le traduisant alors vous
vous donnez maintenant une idée du
contenu de livres du livre il se
décompose en quatre en quatre parties
livre un livre deux je les ai appelés
livre un livre de livres 3 livres 4 qui
font partie de l'ensemble du libre
quatre parties distinctes donc la
première partie qui est assez longue
quand même qui fait un plus de plus d'un
quart du livre c'est un bon tiers en
termes de taille 1 je vous dirais
puisque bon les parties est un condensé
en notation algébrique ça prend moins
d'être moins de place
la première partie il reprend justement
je n'allais pas du tout à l'heure il
reprend le livre de job de cessole
jacobus de ses soli ce qui étonnant que
moins du xiiie siècle il reprend son
livre qui justement donne une
description morale du jeu c'est-à-dire
qui justifie le fait qu'on puisse jouer
à ce jeu donc il va donner tous les
arguments qu'aujourd'hui on connait
c'est un jeu qui est scientifique c'est
un jeu qui permet de travailler le
raisonnement c'est un jeu qui évite les
mauvaises habitudes les mauvaises
pratiques les les
les activités auxquelles se livrent les
soldats qui sont pas toujours des
activités très de très haut niveau donc
ça leur permet ça permet de les recadrer
sur quelque chose qui demande de
l'attention qui
de la réflexion et il va donner aussi
des indications vous savez sur le
fondement historique du jeu dont vous
avez peut-être entendu parler qu'il ya
plusieurs légendes sur l'histoire du jeu
vous avez 6 à l'indien il en parle pas
de ça vous n'allez pas la mède savez
peut-être ça une des légendes du jeu
c'est pas la main qui était un héros
grec qui pendant la guerre de troie vers
aurait inventé ce jeu pour pallier
l'ennui des soldats eh bien c'est dit
quasiment textuellement par mail au ps
on s'est pas quelque chose qui est venu
plus tard c'est déjà cette époque une
légende sur ce sur ce sujet la société
pas celle qui retient même si la donne
il voit là une possibilité déjà lui dont
il n'est pas sûr et il en donne une
autre qui est beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus sûre il parle du philosophe serre
c'est ce cirque cesse ça dépend comment
l'orthographe qui était un qui est elle
un philosophe qui qui étaient autant de
l'un des bus co dolosor qui était un roi
de babylone et qui aurait lui a inventé
ce jeu pour calmer le roi qui avait un
peu d'aidé des tendances sanguinaire
salaire qu'il a tendance à trucider pas
mal ces sujets ce qui est pour le pour
le maintien de la politique était pas
forcément quelque chose de bien et donc
llorente ce jeu pour l'occuper pour lui
faire comprendre que il fallait qu'ils
jouent harmonieusement avec avec sa
population de son pouvoir maintenir son
royaume et c'est d'éviter les invasions
extérieur etc
donc voilà c'est là c'est un peu la
légende il retient et qui décrit assez
longuement donc c'est vraiment
intéressant en termes de témoignages
historiques de
venir les légendes fondatrices du jeu
alors après bien sûr d'en avoir toujours
dans cette première partie il va décrire
enfin les règles du joueur ça ça nous
intéresse parce que d'où viennent les
règles du jeu d'échecs jusqu'aujourd'hui
bon ni journée les rencontres est bien
mais ça vient d'où à quelle époque ça a
été fondé et qu'elle forme avec ses
règles
c'est pas clair et donc la rue lopez va
nous les donner mais nous donnerait de
son époque et c'est là qu'on va
découvrir qu'il ya des légères
différences à son époque il faut savoir
donc ça je me dis sortie du livre on
aura aussi quelques passages tout à
l'heure qu'à cette époque là le portugal
et l'espagne joue aux échecs avec les
mêmes règles mais qu'en italie
signifiant essais les deux pays
on joue le plus en italie les règles
sont différentes il faut savoir dans
comme il est prêtre aussi que c'est rome
qui donne le la serrant la main qui
donne le le tout ce qu'ils les
nouveautés légal les façons de vivre en
société etc
ça vient de rome et du pape et hervé
lopez d'affaires d'ailleurs plusieurs
voyages à rome où il va rencontrer les
italiens dont un fameux italien qu'on
connaît maintenant un peu grâce à lui
qu'on sorte qu'ils aient leonardo da
coûte rien qui va battre alors qu'il est
encore jeune
sans doute 18 ans quand il va donc à
rome pour l'élection du pape
il va pouvoir rencontrer des italiens il
va battre leonardo da coutry mais finira
par perdre le premier championnat du
monde officieux qui sera organisée sur
la fin de sa vie donc serait quand même
quand même un peu âgées 1575 à la cour
d'espagne leonardo d'à côté est indiqué
avec un autre peintre italien paolo boy
est un autre prêtre espagnol info
cruciale pour jouer un match à quatre à
la preuve à la cour du roi d'espagne de
l'époque qui philippe ii d'espagne
fils de charles quint et il perdra
finalement ce championnat du monde cette
sorte de revanche puisque dont qui
l'avait battu il a débattu heures donc
en italie on joue différemment
donc il ya des règles un peu différent
tout en pratique pas en italie la prise
en passant c'est pas c'est pas du tout
pratiquée et comme il le dit il assez
précis dans certains endroits du tali on
se permet de jouer le roi de deux cases
soit à droite soit à gauche
et de rajouter un sceau de la tour par
dessus le rendre mais on reconnaît le
rock mais ne pourrit lopes pas pratiqués
en espagne la pratique au portugal et
pas pratique en italie sauf dans
certains endroits comme il le dit et il
dit que c'est aux règles totalement
absurde puisque il ya aucun jeu et un
vous comme ça deux pièces en même temps
alors ça c'est un témoignage intéressant
le rock à l'épaule n'est pratiquée que
dans certains endroits d'italie ou pas
du tout en fait en général et pour ce
qu'il a prises en passant c'est pas
pratique en italie et rue lopez par
contre va promouvoir la prise en passant
c'est lui il le fait dans ce livre là et
donc semble-t-il avant lui personne le
fait donc si on a la prise en passant
devant lui c'est grâce à rulhe au
présent puisque évidemment quand il fait
autorité dans le jeu d'échecs à l'école
tout ce qui va dire dans ce livre va
avoir une importance considérable pour
la série pour la suite de l'histoire du
jeu donc la prise en passant ivala
promouvoir et il va l'expliquer la
justifier tout y est cette règle
pourquoi on se pose des fois souvent la
question de mais pourquoi cette faille
aux échecs
d'où elle vient quelle est la raison ces
rues au ps qui vous la donne parce que
c'est lui qui va impulser cette aux
règles de la présentation donc ils
wallon décrire toutes ces justifications
alors notamment une double cd soldats il
n'y a pas de raison quand même que ce
fainéant cas pas bougé de toute la
partie il le dit comme ça à un texto web
que ce fait bien qu'elle puisse
s'échapper alors que l'autre a fait tout
le travail pour venir le
le challenge est quoi le venir le lui
mettre un peu la pression
donc ya pas de raison comme ça qu'ils
puissent s'échapper en inde où c'est
très bonne justification et pour l'euro
que j'ai l'impression qu'il a raison on
devrait revoir cette règle alors il n'ya
pas le rock à l'époque
et qu'est-ce qui nous explique dans les
rênes qu'en fait le roi à cette époque
qu'ils ont ça c'est admis donc à la fois
en italie en espagne portugal
donc sauf si incertaine mauritanie où
vous deviez deux fois le roi la rolls
royce à tous en même temps et bien le
rouleur a le droit une fois dans la
partie donc c'est très similaire au rock
en termes de principes
une fois dans la partie à condition de
ne pas être en échec à condition de ne
pas passer sur une case où serait un
échec de jouer de deux cases à la fois
ce qu'il appelle le sceau du roi
d'accord ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire
que premier coup imaginez vous avez les
blancs vous pouvez très bien joué un roi
f3 comme un cavalier ou crois que 3 ou
roi des 3 si vous jouez un c3 comme
cours deuxième coup pour jouer droit ces
deux il joue de deux cases il peut
sauter y compris par dessus ces pièces
d'accord donc voilà le vrai jeu d'échecs
de 1761 n'y a pas de rock il ya cette
règle là donc ça change un peu les
parties mais pas tant que ça parce que
toutes les autres règles du jeu sont les
mêmes
il ya quelques petites différences sur
la flotte partie et on y reviendra tout
à l'heure alors je vais vous lire
maintenant un peu de ce contenu deux
livres par 134 premiers conseils sur les
conditions de jeu vous allez voir ce
qu'il ya des passages un peu amusant
écoutez donc à partir dans cette journée
dans le livre 1
et dans cette deuxième partie après donc
la reprise de la description des pièces
de la description des règles de la
description des légendes du jeu qui le
tire avec commente aussi lui si on y
rajoute
jacques de ses soldats était écrit donc
lui son livre qui est un manuscrit n'est
pas un livre imprimé un congé ce sommet
qui étaient cramés 300 médailles et
repris dans ce livre là donc avec lorie
lopez ont fait coup double puisque on a
un peu le livre déjà vu de ces seuls à
bec et donc dans cette fin dans ce gros
chapitre de cette fin du premier livre
c'est un gros gros chapitre il nous
donne une trentaine de conseils et de
règles de jeu à suivre
et dans le premier écoutez bien première
règle générale du jeu à suivre et que
quand on se mettra à jouer si c'est en
plein jour au soleil de faire en sorte
que l'ennemi et le soleil en face pour
que cela l'aveuglent si c'est dans
l'obscurité et que l'on joue avec une
chandelle de faire en sorte de la voir
sur votre droite pour que cela perdure
de sa vue et fasse de l'ombre à sa main
droite qui parcourt l'échiquier faire de
l'ombre à sa main pas mal de sorte qu'il
ne voit pas bien où les où ces pièces
parce que comme se joue du nez mention
relative à la guerre nous ne l'avons dit
il convient plus que tout autre vieux de
chercher les avantages que de les subir
conformément à ceux-ci que nous dit vers
issus alors si beaucoup d'auteurs latin
ça se faisait beaucoup à l'époque un
monsieur comme divers issus dans le
livre d'un de dv military titre 14 alors
en latin ça donne d'ordinaire tard ou
sociales triade des bêtes dans tes joues
fait pas parce que moi en peluche pas
latinistes j'ai souffert mais j'ai un
collègue heureusement kim a revu ses
dons qui sera hors jeu mais la locution
latine mais il traduit derrière tout
voir donc il nous dit donc ce qui veut
dire donc je vous passe la locution
latine
le commandant km en occident pour la
bataille votre d'abord regardé
considérer trois choses qui sont le
soleil la poussière et le vent pour une
partie d'échecs voyez que ça rigole pas
parce que quand le soleil de face il
aveugle le vent contraire à bas et des
primes les armes a lancé depuis votre
camp et à de celles des adversaires
r la poussière reçu par devant eugene et
aveugle iden
on optera de plus à propos de cette
règle que s'il était égal de jouer plus
avec certaines pièces plutôt que
d'autres et que tu vois que ton ennemi a
l'habitude de jouer plus
particulièrement avec certaines prend
les attentes compte et fait d'avoir
l'habitude de jouer avec elle parce que
cela contribue à le perturber
puisque ensuite on ne joue pas bien avec
les pièces avec lesquelles on n'a pas
l'habitude de jouer comme le dit
aristote et là aussi il va citer donc
une citation d'aristote et donc le hic
est ce qui veut dire que l'ombre parce
que la locution ce qui veut dire que
l'on connaît mieux ce à quoi nous sommes
accoutumés il ya beaucoup d'autres
exemples de ceux ci vous rapportez voilà
et c'est mon premier conseil fait en
sorte de mettre la lumière dans la face
de l'adversaire ou que ça fasse de
l'ombre quand ils jouent de façon à le
gêner c'est assez amusant
voilà donc à l'époque il n'y a pas de
tournoi organisé donc c'est des partis
qui se font un peu de façon comme simple
impromptue dans des conditions diverses
et variées et dont il dit il faut faire
attention à ces conditions ceci dit on
reconnaît là quand même une habitude qui
restaient si vous vous rappelez bien
dans tous les championnats du monde
puisque rappelez vous lors des matchs
star of kharkov et encore même depuis
les joueurs ont des conditions
particulières même si le plus grand mais
sur ces fischer
rappelez-vous le match de fisher il a
demandé à ce que les caméras ne soit pas
là la dominer ce qu'on revoie les
lumières etc
donc en fait issues de conseils de rue
lopez - peut-être qu'il n'avait pas lu
son livre sans doute pas puisqu'il avait
pas été réédité depuis 400 ans mais
voyez bien que quand même ce qu'il dit
là le 6 à 2 par amusant si on regarde
les pratiques du jeu et qui ont été
faites depuis s'est bien repris alors
que vous donner notre conseil qui montre
aussi des caractères ici du niveau de
jeu de riz lopez on regardera aussi des
parties à tout à l'heure
11e conseil écoutez bien 11e conseil 11e
règles à suivre et que le joueur fasse
attention de ne pas laisser depuis
abandonnées ou isolées mais de tâches et
de les garder tous
rooney pas de pions isolé pas mal pour
un joueur de 1561 de les garder toujours
unis les uns avec les autres de sorte
que celui qui est devant puisse être
protégé par celui qui le suit et ceci
sans temps à chaque fois que l'on peut
le faire facilement car les qui ont
isolé se perdent facilement et sont très
difficiles à protéger la plupart du
temps et hélas ce conseil est toujours
valide 1561 on imagine mal à quel point
il maîtriser en fait toutes les
subtilités stratégie que du jus en fait
c'est ça qui est extraordinaire quand on
lit on voit à quel point on n'a rien
inventé en fait alors ainsi mis à part
quand tu as quelque chose à gagner ou
pour une bonne composition de jeu qu'on
pour le voir ou tout autre nécessité qui
peut survenir en dehors de ces cas
qu'ils taxent autant que possible que
les uns soient accompagnés par les
autres comme je le dis parce qu'un six
groupes et ils font mieux la guerre que
leurs ennemis peuvent être mieux aider
des leurs ébats mieux le chemin alors
elle à leurs ennemis afin qu'ils ne
puissent pas passer parce qu'ils s'y
sont éparpillés que les pièces sont
occupés à les protéger
elles ne peuvent pas bien se porter
secours les unes les autres
quand c'est nécessaire comme nous
l'avons expliqué plus haut quand l'armée
s'éparpille et s'ouvre
l'ennemi est mieux équipé pour créer des
ruptures et les démantibulé difficile à
traduire en juin et les démantibulé
selon ce qui a été expliqué dans la 8ème
règles comme nous le montre versus il va
encore citer une location latine etc
bon je vous passe tout parce que c'est
un peu long mais voilà nous explique
bien le problème que les pions isolé
mobilis vos pièces puisqu'il faut les
surveiller tous les uns les autres se
protègent pas les uns les autres et que
sont finalement si une faiblesse
il nous explique bien avec ses mots à
lui avec cette sorte de poésie parce que
voyez comme c'est ces images et avec la
référence toujours à l'art de la guerre
exploit alors autre conseil a pas 150
alors allez les taignonnes concert
écoutez bien alors ça c'est quand j'ai
vu sa gt gt frappé un peu estomaqué me
temime conseillers que le joueur sache
qu'une tour est un fou tous peuvent
gagner la partie contre une tour alors
ça c'est ça c'est que ça déjà toujours
le salon qui sait qu'on peut gagner
touré fou contre tours ici le est la
même georges le ses valeurs pas beaucoup
hein vous êtes trois ou quatre il faut
savoir que la finale touré fou contre
tours sachez le savez peut-être pas mais
voyez qu'on apprend des choses même
avait cru lopez est très souvent
gagnante alors très sonné
la plupart du temps c'est nul il ya une
position qu'on appelle la position de
philidor figurez-vous défini dans ses
200 ans plus tard qui démontre que dans
cette position où le roi est déjà un peu
la bande
et bien en fait même si gagnant de
manière forcée ce qui paraît extrêmement
étonnant se dit touré foulon de retour
on se dit souvent ça suffit pas mais
nancy si ça suffit tori qu'à l'aller
contre autour ça gagne pas mais tous
risques contre tous alors dit dont il
dit que les joueurs sachent qu'une
touriste troupes afghanes et la partie
qu'on eut tour alors par liquidation
comme c'est l'usagé en espagne vous
expliquer ce que ça veut dire et par
matt selon un usage en italie voyez ce
que vous avez dit c'est pas pareil selon
les lieux il le précise il ya des partis
mais miliband voir si orange de la mode
italienne
il faut revoir la partie mais avec
difficulté si l'adversaire c'est bien
joué alors lui aussi il a bien compris
que c'est pas facile à gagner que ça
peut gagner vous dis pas que c'est
gagnant quand même dit que ça tu peux
gagner et que lui-même il est
il salua riz de gagner alors de toute
manière les facile de liquider je vais
vous dire après ce que ça veut dire
parce qu'on peut mettre l'adversaire sur
un côté qui le force à échanger la tour
pour ne pas être mat mais pas pour
donner maths parce qu'il peut se
défendre on se fait remettre patte quand
il se sent enfermé et affligé qui ne
peut bouger en donnant un chèque avec la
tour là où il à perdre à l'adversaire
l'apprendra et le restera pattes mais
comme je l'aï dit et si on sait bien
jouer en donnera matt donc avec tours et
contre tout
et si on sait défendre ce sera avec
beaucoup de difficulté étant donné qu'il
m'est arrivé loi même il m'est déjà
arrivé moi même de donner ce matin des
joueurs d'un niveau raisonnable
donc il avait la pratique il savait que
ça pouvait gagner et que cela lui était
déjà lui-même arrivées des joueurs d'un
niveau raisonnable qui se sont bien
défendus et donc malgré ça il a réussi à
les mater pour finir si celui qui à la
tour c se défendre que l'autre n'est pas
un bon joueur il ne donnera pas mates
à moins que l'adversaire ne s'égare et
ne soient grandement fatigue et amusant
alors on vous a parlé de la liquidation
alors là aussi c'est une règle spéciale
à l'époque avec le sceau du roi
si vous prenez la dernière pièce de
l'adversaire d'accord si vous prenez la
dernière pièce de l'adversaire la partie
s'arrête et vous avez une sorte de trois
quarts deux victoires en fait on
considère c'est pas vraiment une partie
nulle quand même parce que vous avez
livré plus de pied très longue mais on
va pas jusqu'au maths c'est pas la peine
ce qui a plus de pièces et on considère
que c'est pas une victoire pleine ce qui
complique le jeu parce que ça signifie
que dans la finale dames et roi contre
roye epyon d'accord qui est la plupart
du temps gagnante
sauf dans des cas a vraiment
exceptionnel où le pion c7 et e7 on le
sait aujourd'hui mais dans ce cas là si
vous prenez le pion
la partie s'arrête il ya pas mates dont
vous ne prenez que trois quarts de la
mise presque là il parle beaucoup de
gains de paris un second temps on ne
prend que trois quarts du paris et non
pas la totalité
donc faut pas prendre l'option pour
gagner alors ceci implique que alors
page 154 et ne me dit
25e règles si le jour le col aux joueurs
prennent en compte que si l'ennemi à en
finale la dame et lui pas plus qu'on
pille on monte jusqu'à l'avant dernière
case avant de pouvoir faire dame call
usage de l'espagne le jeu ne sera pas
plus qu'une liquidation comme pour mater
il faudra prendre le pion la partie
s'arrête vous ne vouliez pas la finale
roi aidé à me contre euro action si le
pionner sur la dernière rangée qu'elle
ou il soit en fait pour port et lopez à
cette époque alors qu'aujourd'hui il
faut savoir c'est gagné la plupart du
temps sauf si le roi est un [ __ ] pions
et ans et 7 ou 9 7
parce qu'en ce cas là le roi se cachant
à 8 ou en fuite et avec la dame on prend
le pion et ses pattes mais pour louis
lopez un tout autre cas quand on prend
le pion c'est nul donc le pire étant sur
la dernière on peut pas gagner parce que
sinon on a les autres car nous on garde
en prenant pions d'abord une suite au
film fait math aveyron et dames 3
d'accord ce qui fait que ça complique
messieurs pions et à deux classes de dan
alors écoutez bien elle celle de
l'espagne le jeu ne sera pas plus donc
une liquidation ci dont bien sûr la 7e
j'entends avec le roi adverse éloigné du
sien parce qu'autrement et ne pourrait
il se pourrait qu'il ne laisse pas le
privilège de faire dame et du mat
mais s'il manque aux pions deux cases
pour faire dame et que l'adversaire le
roi ou la dame positionné devant pour
qu'il ne puisse pas avancer dans l'idée
c'est qu'on bloque le qui ont su laurent
est à deux doigts de faire d'un par
exemple le pion et dans ces six dépensé
sept îles et ans et 6 ont bloqué le pion
avec le roi donc on a le rôle à la
positionner devant pour qu'ils puissent
pas relancer si la colonne et celle des
cavaliers ou détour par contre et ne
laissant ni ne permettant qu'ils ne se
mettent sur la ligne de la tour sur la
sur la ligne à
ce ne sera pas mat c'est pourquoi à
chaque fois que l'adsl serra de le
mettre sur le titre cologne la fura de
toutes les manières et fera en sorte que
la dame adverse va y attirer le roi par
les diagonales étoiles un grand terrain
bon bref il faut retenir ici c'est que
si le kurita de cases de faire de bruit
lopez c'est une théorie tri
de la nôtre on bloque le pion pour unité
qu'il avance le monsieur mugabé l'orage
a fait des tests et avec la dame on va
amener le roi dans un coin un accord et
une fois qu'il est dans un coin droit
quitte le blocage du pion pour aider la
dame fermathe l'adversaire le temps car
dame puisqu'il va avancer son pire une
fois deux fois je vous rappelle qu'il
faut pas le prendre pour hulot ps
liquidation sinon le roi avance une fois
deux fois et il va aider à faire le
match et si le curé trop loin il
explique ici je vous parce que c'est une
subtilité un peu long à expliquer si le
pion et sur a ou b le roi est en âge
suite
la dame peut donc le coin si là-bas mais
le temps que le roi arrive en atten de
faire damer ensuite de faire des échecs
et donc on n'est pas mates faut pas que
l'option sont sûrs à libé ou bien sûr
j'ai h évidemment cette règle
aujourd'hui n'a pas n'a pas besoin
d'abord cours puisqu'on a droit à nous
de prendre le pion une finir voilà donc
c'est à noter cette troisième façon de
finir la partie à l'époque il ya matière
pâte déjà fort bien la liquidation et ça
change certaines finales alors ensuite
en termes de livres on va passer les
noms au parti donc ça c'était donc la
première partie avait tous ces conseils
rien à +30 conseil 30 règles vous passez
un subit lisez le livre vous allez vous
régaler à regarder tout ça et on ne veut
pas vous faire une lecture complète du
livre c'est impossible
le livre de ce sont des conseils de rui
lopez que de son cru à lui comment jouer
les parties avaient toutes les
ouvertures et c'est dans le niveau 3 est
très intéressant parce qu'il reprend le
livre dont on a du joueur dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure qui est
damiano dagano qui hélas royer qui est
contemporain bruit au ps voyez même s'il
meurt alors cory lopez est encore jeune
damiano ses débuts en fait c'est fin d
année 1430 début des amis 500c après
lucena donc à vendre avant que lopez il
a écrit son livre qui faisait autorité
qu henri lopes s'est mis à jouer aux
échecs c'est ce livre de damiano qui
faisait autorité en fait effectivement
il est bourré de fautes techniques et il
va se régaler rue lopez a cassé de
damiano en fait le livre iii et reprend
ça c'est génial parce que c'est
aujourd'hui ça suit - quoique un auteur
comme ça reprenne tout un livre d'un
autre pour expliquer là où il a tort par
tous il reprend le leader damiano et
toutes ces ouvertures etc et il va
s'amuser à réfuter un parent une par une
les parties que ne proposent que nous
propose damiano pour expliquer de ça
c'est pas bon parce que ceci parce que
cela et nous proposent les bons coups et
c est tout le livre iii c'est quasiment
c'est ça pas tout à fait la fin du livre
c'est assez s'est passé pas tout à fait
ça et on fait donc un livre iv dont on
verra pas de partie mais quelle romain
aussi intéressant le livre iv ce sont
des conseils de louis lopez sur les
partis a avantage à les parties avantage
c'est encore un peu aujourd'hui mais pas
vraiment de théorie là-dessus alors à
l'époque il a passé un tout un chapitre
tout un chapitre iv à nous expliquer les
différents de les différentes façons
pour une grand joueurs d'essayer de
jouer des parties avantageant qu'est ce
qu'ils appellent les parties avantage
c'est les parties où vous donnez un pur
en l'adversaire en techniquement il vous
conseille de prendre le pion f2 pour les
noirs prend le pion f2 c'est parce que
ce sont eux qui défend le roi et ses
banques j'explique comment aussi tirer
avantage de sa mais il peut y avoir des
partis gordon
vallier des parties où l'adversaire a
déjà le roi en a huit
il a pour 1 8 permet d'avoir le roi déjà
à l'abri dès le départ c'est vrai qu'il
ya plein davantage différents unis
traitent tous et il donne un exemple de
parties de comment essayer de traiter ça
ce que j'aime c'est évidemment puisque
oui c'est mal partis quand vous avez un
doute bien moins une pièce de moins ça
finit par coûter cher mais c'est
intéressant de voir que dans son lit qui
s'est sentie obligée de le faire ça veut
dire que la pratique était courante
alors quand c'était un jeu d'argent je
pense que c'est voulu c'est fait pour
les bons joueurs quand donner des
chances à des joueurs moins forts de
façon à ce qu'ils jouent parce que sinon
ils n'acceptent pas de jouer son qui
leur donne un avantage à en espérant
quand même gagné la mise
donc voilà il vous proposions quoi
aujourd'hui on peut aussi mais moins
aujourd'hui ont quand même on est
beaucoup nous a joué par passion ne
cherche pas tous à être des
professionnels des chèques et là il
parle vraiment en tant que professionnel
on le sent il joue avec des
professionnels ils jouent de l'argent
même si lui il est prêtre c'est pas son
activité principale mais pour jouer il
était obligé de miser coin sinon les
joueurs n'acceptent pas voilà donc on va
regarder un peu quelques parties ap une
fois qu'on aura vu c'est parti on va en
voir de 2,3 et bien une fois qu'on aura
qu on aura vu ça sonne bien non
si vous avez des questions eh bien je
réponds alors un petit mot d'abord dans
ce livre iii sur le haut d'un country
dont vous avez parlé tout à l'heure par
trois simples écoutez bien parce qu'il
ya des témoignages il se livre comme
j'ai tout repris 1 j'ai rien enlever à
le foot outillés alors que tt ça
témoignages des rues lopez qui est au
milieu d'une partie comme ça qu'a
l'argovienne c'est un témoin historique
est vraiment fascinant qui compte une
partie l'autre raison pour laquelle il
faut jouer des 4 et de voir pousser le 5
quand ils combien attaquant un cavalier
tout en restant protégé par le club
importé d'allemagne on a touché du doigt
au coeur de ces points puisque je vous
dédie le livre iii il trittico damiano
il arrive donc à damier ne répétez
énormément fois dans cette partie là
damian on a touché du doigt que ces
ponts son début et enjoué par quelques
joueurs principalement face à ce qu'ils
en savent pas beaucoup les mazérois et
du divin tout ça lorsqu'elle vous savez
nos moutons
la ligne 10 comme ça ce qu'ils en savent
pas beaucoup cela fut même joué quelques
fois face à man il parle du dandy
damiano ici vous savez candidats mios et
de 4,5 carrière 3 et énergie elle six
voiliers on protège le pion aux cinq par
le pion f ce qui est considéré comme un
mauvais coup et il ya toute une partie
de ce livre 3 puisque c'est le lambda
minot a été analysé par des mineurs où
il explique la façon de prévenir et de
traiter ce début pas tout à fait bonnes
et ses rues de dresde sommes la première
grande d'ailleurs réfutation de ceux de
samedi
à noter que j'avais vu la théorie de en
guidant dans l'encyclopédie vous savez
des échecs et édité par de nouveaux
slave dans les années 80 90 et il y
avait toute la théorie et bien cette
théorie que je connaissais et
entièrement expliquée par rui lopez en
fait donc ça fait presque y avait plus
de quatre cent cinquante ans qu'on
connaît la réputation complète du début
damiano et elle a été réalisée par me
lopez
c'est le premier en fait qu'il a fait
at-elle boisnant que cette théorie est
toujours dans les
dans les grandes villes de théorie dans
toute toute la théorie officielle du jeu
qui est dans un cycle de vie donc cela
fut même joué quelques fois par mois
face à moi par jour estimé qui se
faisait appeler l muchacho des laumes
ce qui veut dire le garçon ne rendons le
jeune garçon drôme l'adolescent de rang
lors de cette chaude et roma quand il
dit ça ça m'a frappé l'île vient ça m'a
fait penser ou kit de brooklyn
vous savez que qui de brooklyn vous avez
dit ces voix-là bobby fischer l'appeler
comme ça lucky de brooklyn c'est le
jeune joueur au clean donc là il parle
ou chat sur des normes annoncé une sorte
de bobby fischer l'époque
si vous voulez et séoul s'est sans doute
léonard dans la poterie donc à rome au
début du pontificat du pape pie 4 en
l'an mille cinq cent soixante dix même
la datar 1566 donc pas un an avant la
parution de ce livre
ceci étant noté il revient son sujet etc
voilà donc cette petite anecdote il est
d'une partie nous indique un en 1560 il
est allé à rome et de lui il est sans
doute il a joué face à une chaîne sur
des romains alors on n'est pas sûr que
ce soit leonardo poterie puisque c'est
pas écrit textuellement et on peut se
douter que ces lignes il est à peu près
l'âge et ou alors c'est paulo boys et l
autre italien qui d'ailleurs avec moi
que avait 32 ans de ce que j'ai noté
mais très bien c'est un peu âgé quand
même ton ferme au cha cha cha ou
sculpteurs adolescent a envoyé donc
c'est plutôt entre 15 et 25 ans maximum
donc pour ce petit cette petite cette
petite anecdote alors pense 316 toujours
pour parler damiano ont coûté bien il
nous dit
ah oui bon c'est pour l'origine du
vocable bambi mais d'où ça vient
d'emmener ce que vous savez mon dire
gambie ça vienne italien exactement
c'est ça ouais c'est ça a mûri au mieux
peut être lu le livre aussi vous avez
écouté la vidéo peut-être j'ai fait vous
êtes à peu intéressé d'accord alors
c'est ça effectivement
écoutez bien alors oui le buzz de
m'expliquer donc là on a la plus vieille
explications mais c'est exactement ça
quant à la dernière des choses que nous
avons promis de déclarer dans ce
chapitre il convient de savoir que le
vocable gambeat nous vient de la langue
italienne ses proches de l'italienne
gamba qui veut dire jambes qui veut dire
gendrin espagnols m'ont offert en
français les moments si difficiles à
traduire la poste ou traduits en
français il parle en espagne et gand
guitare et chant guitare et donc un
italien veut dire dans notre castillan
donc montrant ses armes et rencontrant
des gens me préparer pour cointreau
qu'enjambe effectivement que plus tard
et ça veut dire préparer un contrôle
interne et de là le jeu du gambit tu
veux dire je delà c'est le laisser les
chaussures on possible de stopper le
lacet jeu de l'acier des programmes car
oui c'est une bonne pièce génomique
environ sacrifier un pion essentiel de
plaire davantage
par ailleurs alors et il dit que de
toutes les parties que damien composent
il n'a pas composé leurs données depuis
parfaite ni comprenant plus de pièges
que cette partie là il dit quand même
que bien que ils sont allés plus loin
dans l'explication du dôme il explique
il estime que c'est sans doute la partie
de derrière nous la plus juste et la
plus avancée
on l'a aussi des 10 dans ce livre ont
fait coup double avec la reprise par
henri lopes du livre de chèques de ses
soldats commise le 6 au 10 mai on fait
aussi coup triple puisqu'il reprend
quasiment l'intégralité de livres de
damiano quelques pâtes qu'il va
commenter donc on a on a trois livres
dans un an qu'elle peut sortant alors
voir sur les parties vous allez voir
parce qu'on voit des choses
vraiment intéressante alors page 323 on
va enfin regarder une des parties du
livre pour parler du jeu d'échecs
proprement dit alors pages donc 323 et
la variante simple quidam des quatre
d'accord donc on y va alors et 4.5 kf3
donc qui nous expliquent des débuts
beaucoup moins fait ainsi beaucoup de
début de partie mais il va jusque loin
et souvent jusqu'au match ça arrive ce
qu'ils agissent comme at our jusqu'à un
avantage net ou baies 5 pouces et 5
alors qu'ils nous expliquent que c'est
que son commentaire lui pour que le foot
ne restent pas enfermés voyez on joue
ces scènes avant jouer des 6 mars que le
foot soit pas derrière les pions
donc là il propose france et 6 des
princes et 6 et nous dit que c'est
meilleur que prendre du pib meilleur que
b processes ce que nous verrons plus
tard m'expliquera ça plus tard et alors
cinq cavaliers 54.5 et la lente alors la
partie principale commence par faut
prendre en f2
mais ils nous proposent une autre
variante ici donc si c'est là mon regard
des variantes d'amd 4 alors qui a l'air
très fort en attaque le cavalier 1,5 et
le point car on se dit pourquoi il
montre sa bonté
un piège on a un peu de bruit je pense
que ce n'est pas là on a un piège ici
d'un des quatre alors est ce que vous
voyez des réponses
il ya deux réponses ici non pas perdre
la partie tout de suite alors il ya soit
cavaliers detroit qui protégeait de soi
l'autre coup cavale et j 4 c'est
surprenant mais vous allez voir ça
marche alors nous dit vous ne prenez pas
le cavaliere est que fout si vite
malgré le fait qu'on se dise il faut
prendre ça l'airborne parce que qu'est
que cela semble beaucoup ce n'est pas le
cas et les meilleurs de prendre le point
4 alors j'ai mis un commentaire là parce
que je suis dit qu'est ce que c'est une
histoire qu'on comprend mal cavaillé
s'avère très forme surtout prendre les
quatre d'apprendre les quatre avec les
blancs d'un prof de droit des uns le roi
peut venir en d1
les blancs ont pris un des deux buts de
des deux fois de version preview s'est
vite éliminant ainsi la dangereuse de
terre de fond il reste avec une majorité
des pions centre et oui parce qu'on est
allé le club des 3 et 4
au centre le clown en alena non plus et
il fait froid ce des rockets d'accord il
faut éviter aussi de juger la position
avec des critères modernes parce qu'ici
les noirs ne peuvent pas rugby je vous
rappelle qu'à pas le rock on ne peut que
sauter avec le roi donc on peut pas
juger la position tout à fait avec free
les critères actuels on ne peut que
transposer ils appellent ça la
transposition en 2000 c'est à dire qu on
pourra avec les noirs jouent et touré
suite plus tard on joue d'abord pour
essuyer ensuite 3g vite mais simplement
de
on prend pas faire le rapport puisque la
dame g4 contreras la gâteau la casse
s'est vite ce qui change donc
radicalement estimations la position
allongée que vous assurez vous pourrez
le vérifier j'ai testé la position de
montréal est fier quand même sur un
ordinateur
v la région la position est avantageuse
au blanc four conjugales il faut dire à
l'ordinateur par contre on n'a pas de
rendre au quai vous savez on peut lui
dire est ce que le rock est encore
possible ou pas dans le paramètre vous
pouvez dire maintenant on leur payait
pas d'europe possible hélas l'ordinateur
donne une légère avantage aux blancs
très étonnant voilà mais lyon que ça
veut dire aussi que le jugement nourrit
lopez m'a dit qu'il est très fort parce
que bien que se coupe à rester forts
sont rangés 4 mais il n'est pas tant que
ça donc voilà donc c'était intéressant
pour ça donc je continue quand même un
peu d'en prendre quatre échecs
voyez cavaillon 3 qui ont agi et vous
expliquant même c'est bon pour les noirs
se disent mais c'est mieux que la
baronne précédente
ici la loi parce qu'après [ __ ] en 3d
prendre trois elle est en projet de vie
ici et après tout f1 fou h3 bien sûr est
très forte
d'accord ici il ya un gros problème sur
la torah chien il va falloir la torre ça
il va falloir défendre avec la dame en
deux et on va voir souci on peut aussi
jouer ici alors en fait ils nous
proposent même tout fou g4 à date la
dame et gagne aussi la partie de manière
de manière forcée
alors ensuite donc ça c'est bon pour
cette variante alors la variante aussi
six cavaliers detroit
donc après dans le dkv justement voilà
donc l'autre possibilité ici après dans
des quartiers on l'a vu tout à l'heure
c'est de jouer le coup cavaliers en d3
donc la salers mieux puisque sa protégée
veut donc il nous montre ces drames
voyez donc il est assez exhaustif un
protège du mat et attaque luz et cinq
d'entre eux quatre échecs dans le 2 la
dame maintenant est flou et donc les
changes des dames on va être obligé
disent que c'est le mieux que les blancs
peut se jouer d'un franc et deux échecs
croit prendre deux pelés maintenant fou
b6 c4 menace d'en fermer le fou un
parent c5
attention ici donc il nous le dit
d'ailleurs qu'on gagne le fou b6 ou
l'enfermer ce qui semble être un bon
coup voilà ce qu'il nous dit faux fc
attaque
le cavalier donc en cas de ces cinq on
prend d'abord le cavalier avec échec
puis on perdrait le pion c5
ici donc cavalier ce pardon fou donc f5
cavalier e
regardez son cavalier pour remédier donc
à la menace et ouvrir la voie aux
phocéens oui bien sûr on sort le
cavalier pour pouvoir jouer le pion des
et sortir ce se font cavalier de 6 des 3
et la wii alors là les coûts énormes ici
dans cette position on vous laisse y
réfléchir deux minutes qu'a pu jouer rue
lopez ici on se dit grand roc ou petit
rock s'alarmer a même qu'en europe c'est
sans doute très bien mais on n'a pas le
droit brooke est ce qu'on aimerait
laisser finir le développement ces
derniers les tours finalement pour les
mettre au centre
donc il ya un très beau coup que je peux
pas saisir sur l'échiquier
vous allez voir alors je vais le faire
ici regardez up roger 6 1 voyez donc
celle assez surprenant alors j'ai pas dû
le saisir le roi g6 et qui ronge et si
oui normal alors à chaque fois j'ai mis
un commentaire à chaque fois qu'ils
avaient un sens durant il y en a
plusieurs mais sur qui dit toujours un
sceau du roi cette fois en diagonale
donc et j'ai rajouté
on ne s'y fait pas facilement évidemment
comme pouvoir rejouer relais si wes et
parce que lui mais aucun commentaire
c'est un peu normal pour lui si vous
jouez rejet si cet après midi dans vos
open je vous assure les arbitres vont au
bout sermonnés mais vous pourrez dire
mais c'est la théorie monsieur g j'ai la
preuve
roger 6 voilà donc ici la partie
continentale on est très belle cette
partie c'est peut-être une peut-être la
plus belle
ah oui il faut aussi que je dise que
c'est aux blancs de jouer non parce que
pour lui pour l'ordinateur là et c'est
pas du tout le goût légal je peux pas le
jouer comme un autre coup un donc je lui
explique que je fais autre chose là donc
fou 3 oui mais à part ça à toutes les
règles sont les mêmes c'est vraiment
pour ça qu'il arrive de la liquidation
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure qui
change un peu les finales mais sinon
toutes et tous tes semblables
donc ça change un tout petit peu c'est
un peu plus subtil mais papa beaucoup
plus en fait finalement tu auras schmitt
clou le fou 3 détroit pour éviter le
clou face à des mélodies d'ailleurs des
clous le fou
3 vous prendre pour éviter que le feu se
fasse enfermé par ces cinq voiliers faut
prendre peut prendre trois des huit ici
cavalli ces trois cavaliers g4 fait
pression ici sur le pion sur le pion de
trois quarts aile et d un protège le
tuant 3 mais voyez comme ces cavaliers
sont quand même sur la première rangée
les tours blanches sont pas liés voyez
le développement noir et très harmonieux
on voit ne serait-ce qu'à l'oeil que les
flamands c'est bon pour les bons pour
les membres maintenant cavalier eu cinq
attaques l'option de trois et ainsi
gagner la partie
jolie partie qu'un beau développement
il ya encore une variante derrière on va
l'avoir
c'est celle qui conclut cette partie
magnifique vallée voir ici alors si au
15e coup alors aujourd'hui où j'en suis
le roi 2
on en sait après prise prise d'otages et
oui voilà oui là ici dans cette position
il remet le roi en e2 cette variante là
alors c'est assez joli pour la russie
c'est bien celle-là cavale et j'ai
quatre attaques de 3 e 4 ça protège
c'est une façon de protéger sacrifices
donc c'est un si joli si on prend tout
reprend un échec
roy f3 et à leurs bombes s'attaque de
pièces ou bien alors on nous explique si
le roi était venu en f1 simplement joue
tour des seins et voyez que ça empêche
les ailes dame de bouger et le cavalier
ici sera permet donc au moins je couds
quoi donc ici au regard des tours et
trois reproches et 4 et forcé d'accord
ou alors au f4 mais ça revient à la même
chose
et enfin tour des quatre échecs et mat
pas mal mais l'analyse de rue lopez la
sauce est renvoyée nous montre quand
même des parties jusqu'à un niveau
avancé avec des façons de jouer depuis
delhi des conseils vous expliquer on
prend des preuves de développement du
fou des problèmes de biens magnifique
ouvrage ici cela bon qu'il faut essayer
de placer ça si vous arrive à placer
rôle et six dans une partie c'est quand
même pas mal
voilà donc alors ensuite il ya une autre
oui il ya un autre point que je voulais
voir et puis ce sera le dernier point
qui est intéressant je peux pas m'en
passer de plus ça fait déjà nuit ça va
faire une presque une heure c'est bien
ça reste une demi heure
et les questions réponses donc c'est un
point très important en termes
historiques aussi pas 300 points ça fait
écho ça va ferrer cours la conférence
que je vais donner vendredi sur philidor
la ligue 1 voilà ce chapitre page 69
une autre façon de mener la partie
contre l'offensive des cavaliers f3 et
selon la deuxième manière de défendre
envoyé le nom des chapitres est un peu
un peu poétique
ils sont tous comme ça et j'ai tout
repris je te repris parce que on revient
là l'intérêt du livre avant tout
historique donc c'est se plonger dans
cette époque cette façon de présenter le
jeu alors regardez cette partie il nous
propose ce cadre le 5
c'est une autre façon de protéger il va
passer vite en même temps à répondre à
cavalière trois noms qui va proposer des
six il va proposer f6 qui est la défense
de damiano l'intérêt des l'cie ce même
si bien sûr on sait aujourd'hui que
c'est un mauvais coup mais l'intérêt de
jouer psy c'est à dire le plein du du
fou du roi là le point f 7 ans et 6 c en
protège le pion aux cinq en laissant le
fouet suite libre de sortir c'est ça
l'intérêt de secours le problème c'est
ça se heurte à cavalier champions 5 et
il va passer énormément de temps à
analyser ça damiano déjà qualifié assez
bien mais lui valent un peu plus loin
puisqu'il va jusqu'à la valeur théorique
moderne n'a pas changé depuis et qui est
toujours correct ça qui est assez de
blancs bien à noter que c'est une partie
justement ya pas de rock on n'a pas le
temps parce que c'est une attaque
violente contre le roi et que ce soit
les blanc et noirs
1 donc c'est ça change pas que ce soit
la théorie de louis lopez de celle
moderne ça fera l'analyse
donc il passé en un an de temps hélas
ici nous propose un regard des poufs des
6es des six s'appelle comment la défense
philidor c'est pas fini d'or qui la
donnent 6 rue lopez
donc là on va avoir un problème de
paternité la mairie on est quand même
deux cents ans en finance 1561 qui dans
son livre en 1749
mais c'est pire que ça parce qu'après
tout c'est 4 par une opel nous propose
l500 on sait aujourd'hui que c'est pas
très bon coup parce que sa soeur comme
bull suivante descartes ou pascal
théorie mais on vous des 4es en cas de
reprise en 4 comprend 1,5 avec
lecavalier avec une grosse attaque c'est
assez précis c'est assez théorique ça
donne un petit avantage aux blancs
peu importe ce qui est intéressant ici
c'est un devoir que des sites proposés
déjà parcouru par milo quasi qu'ils
estiment être le meilleur plus
d'ailleurs mieux que calais c6 lebouc
avait laissé si ce n'est qu'il défend
avec la manière espagnol 1 d'accord
après ici dans cette position là les
noirs peuvent protéger de ce cavalier la
blessure ça c'est là la fameuse défense
rue lopez bien sûr ils analysent dans le
livre mais geek c'est bon pour les
blancs damian on vous propose de cavalli
c6 en fait
et oui lopez gibaja poule b celle qu'il
n'a pas analysé et qui est très fort
d'accord je vous passe on ne fait pas la
passe que c'est un peu long et c'est si
le coeur du livre mais c'est quand même
c'est quand même intéressant mais ici ce
qu'il faut noter c'est que c'est la
manière de jouer la défense philidor ici
qui est celle exactement proposé par
philidor dans son livre il la joue avec
f5 les scénarios qu'on pourrait penser
proposé par phillies ont en fait existe
déjà dans le livre de rui lopez donc en
interne parc de maternité on pourrait
presque l'appelait aussi défense rio
ça serait pas faux mais bon là on a
considéré philidor alors peut-être que
l'analyse de philidor aussi plus longue
plus précises parce que les partis de
rue le prêt soit un peu plus courte
aussi un ça va un peu moins noir voilà
donc c'est intéressant à noter en termes
d'histoire de paternité voyons retrouve
ces choses là
à noter je vous montre pas ici que en
terme théorique aussi en termes
d'ouverture ils vous proposent très peu
de bonnes ouvertures du kandhamal passe
quasiment son temps à faire du pied
droit dacquois mais ya quand même une
dame et ils vous proposent aussi avec
les noirs après eux car le coût des cinq
que vous connaissez sans doute comme
étant la défense scandinave verruyes
lopez 2 propose déjà l'espagne pour la
scandinavie c'est quand même pas le même
endroit
voyez mais c'est déjà dans son nid vide
et on peut aussi défendre comme ça mais
il passera beaucoup de temps l'analyse
est pas contre mais ils montrent que
c'est possible
bon voila voila je crois que je vais
arrêter là pour la présentation de ce
livre générale il ya beaucoup d'autres
choses mais c'est évidemment impossible
de faire plus savez ça fait une heure
que je vous ai quand même proposer du
contenu de ceux de ce livre que j'ai
vraiment pris beaucoup de plaisir à
traduire j'ai à peu près mis deux ans
entre le début et la finition est donc
si vous avez des questions mais nancy le
moment alors prenez le micro et vous
venez la poser la question micro
que sur le rock j'avais lu cherchant sur
internet que c'était encore l'époque de
la banque de henri iv c'était pour
mettre le royaume reste c'est quelque
chose qu'elle génère vous pouvez alors
je ne peux pas dire si si c'est souvent
ric être que ça a été officialisée mais
je sais que je peux dire par contre
c'est plusieurs choses c'est que les
règles du jeu n'ont été officialisée de
manière générale dans tous les pays qui
jouent aux échecs que fin du 19e siècle
et c'est pour ça qu'on a pu organiser un
championnat du monde allait steinitz
d'accord les italiennes déjà encore
jusque dans le 19ème siècle jouer avec
avec leurs règles a eu notamment comme
le dit philidor aussi dans son livre au
18e les règles entre l'angleterre et la
france sont pas les mêmes
par exemple en angleterre le pack gagné
la partie
à l'époque de philidor à l'épaule de rue
lopez la france l'angleterre ou même
l'allemagne ne joue pas aux échecs ou
vraiment à presles montré très peu de
jambes les gros pays on joue c'est
l'espagne le portugal et l'italie
et comme le dirait lopez sait que le
rock existe déjà puisqu'il le site il
dit dans certains endroits italie on se
permet de jouer le roi dodo casa droite
ou de cases à gauche et la tour qui
passe par dessus il le dit accepter
jarre
donc c'est déjà existant mais donc c'est
pas uniformisées voilà donc je peux pas
dire parfois à quel moment s'est
officialisé entre guillemets le mais si
ce n'est de dire que les règles du jeu
d'échecs de manière générale ont été
officialisés qu'à la fin du 19e avant le
championnat du monde de steinitz et
c'est pour ça qu'on l'a appelée
championnat du monde et avant comme il y
avait tellement de disparités de règles
des subtilités parfois un mais c'était
tellement différent qu'on peut pas dire
qu'il y avait un jeu unis et comme il
est pas de jeu unis
on ne peut pas dire que les règles
étaient vraiment établi qu je crois
avoir lui aussi le ciel après l'euro
alors c'est possible je peux pas alors
là je peux pas conclure ensuite parce
que j'ai j'ai commencé à travailler sur
le livre de lucena mais c'est d'abord
actuellement ce que j'ai fait c'est que
j'ai récupéré le contenu du livre ce qui
est passée un peu déjà mais j'ai pas
encore lu le contenu
donc j'ai pas vu sur les déplacements la
dame dans ce cas je pourrais conclure
parce que ces 497 le hideux le sénat
mais ce que je peux dire par contre ça
c'est intéressant sur la dame je sais
pas si on le nom de la dame est venue
ensuite sans doute parce que bien sûr
alors faut savoir qu'en 4 997 l'espagne
la même année d'ailleurs christophe
colomb découvre la mairie 492 l'espagne
finit ce qu'on appelle la reconquête par
les pompistes parce que les mots ont
occupé l'espagne de l'an 800 jusqu'en 14
192 justement d'accord le dernier roi
maure a quitté l'espagne c'est boabdil
qui abdique en 492 c'est les rois
catholiques isabelle de castille qui
reprend cette dernière ville à ce moment
là est donc mis sur le jeu d'échecs a
été introduit en espagne par les morts
c'est l'aimant bien sûr donc le fait que
ça s'appelle caen vire c'est tout à fait
possible et bien sûr avec la royauté
c'est sans doute devenu la dame où la
reine et là il ya un petit mot à dire
sur wii lopez
parce qu'ils en parlent ils parlent de
cette pièce il va vous décrire toutes
les pièces une par une et il explique
pourquoi la cette forme
pourquoi la salle ce nom et d'où ça
vient et c'est des gros chapitres ont
fait c'est du gros chat puis il ya bien
dommage à chaque fois sur chaque pièce
quoi donc c'est intéressant en termes de
témoignages d'origine
du nom des pièces il nous parle de la
dame il nous parle pas de cette histoire
de grand vizir donc malheureusement là
c'est pas je ne peux pas conclure mais
il nous dit on dit donne ou rennes
d'accord donc c'est intéressant de dire
aussi parce que moi j'ai entendu les
gens l'ont dit dame depuis la révolution
française soit disant parce que la reine
on lui a coupé la tête et tout venant
pas du tout ce que rui lopez déjà andy
d'amour-haine ce alors que comme le jeu
est ancien il le dit bombe à l'époque la
puna bucco d'honneur c'est pas vraiment
un roi mais c'est plutôt un grand moufti
j'en sais rien je sais pas
les lilas il a une suite avec lui la
plus à même quoi donc il ya des dames et
il n'y a pas de rennes à proprement
parler c'est un premier point alors mais
on dirait nos dames il le dit mais dans
le livre ça je voulais noté parce que
j'ai fait une recherche après je le dis
dans les commentaires je n'ai pas le
chiffre est exact mais il va citer le
monde dames
il va donner le monde dames genre
quelque chose comme 200 x et le mans
rennes il va l'utiliser que 20 fois
donc bien que déjà à l'époque il accepte
le fait il dit qu'on peut dire rennes où
dame sera pour les mesures il va
utiliser d'armes plutôt n'utilise
presque parraine en fait donc ça c'est
intéressant a noté
voilà deux sets il ressort de ce livre
là que le terme dame était déjà pris le
prédominant bien qu'on puisse dire les
deux déjà à cette époque comme on est là
au début du jeu d'échecs en europe
voilà on peut se dire que c'est quand
même c'est quand même important
oui oui sans doute exactement tout à
fait voilà donc pas si vous avez une
autre question ont tellement sur ce
livre vous à vous et de saône et là
c'est très riche on pourrait au courant
on pourrait faire un tournoi à la règle
avec les raiders une opel ça changerait
ça changerait un petit peu bompas pas
tant que ça finalement quand vous avez
vu ça change pas énormément non plus
c'est pas une très grande différence
mais c'est une petite utilité amusante
et puis ça nous reconnecte à l'histoire
du jeu c'est on peut dire que c'est que
c'est validé que c'est les règles de la
physique seconde raison c'est là c'est
l'ancienneté qui prime il faut aussi de
faire valoir sa dans l'open cet après
midi ça va pas être simple
ça vaut g c'est bon merci d'avoir suivi
alors j'ai quelques exemplaires ici de
ce livre donc si vous voulez dans la
semaine où aujourd'hui sous les
dédicaces et bien sûr mais je suis je
suis disponible
merci à tous
rempl
dédicace